Let's look at the solution to
our N-module redundancy quiz
where we had three computers that are
totally identical on the same desk, and
we use them as a three module or
redundant system.
And the question is what type
of event can we always overcome?
A single alpha particle strike is going
to effect only a single processor, and
that means that the two computers
that are not affected by this will
still agree.
A building collapse will
either be another building and
not affect anything, but if it is
the building in which these systems are,
then the building collapse is probably
going to destroy all three computers, so
we cannot tolerate this type of event.
Earthquake is going to do
a similar thing, and a mistake
in processor design, because the three
are identical, if there is a mistake in
processor design it's going to affect
all three processors at the same time.
So, again, we cannot tolerate this.
So as you can see, replicating
the hardware with identical hardware and
in an identical location
only really ensures that we can survive
something like a particle strike.
If we wanted to tolerate earthquakes and
building collapses,
we would need to geographically
distribute these three computers.
If we want to tolerate
a mistake in processor design,
we would need to use three computers
with different processors.
So the N-module
redundancy doesn't really
guard against these types of
faults unless the modules
are in different places and
of different designs.